bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti questo
video sono fa vj oggi siamo tornati su
the strange adventures che tanti ragazzi
notizie sempre più [ __ ] ogni volta ogni
giorno che passa ad ora è giusto il
gioco alla follia raga la prima volta
che l'ho visto quindi non vedo l'ora di
continuare lo son già morto fantastico
io capire un attimo con me niente questo
va avanti da solo so se è normale
l'ultima volta non era così
porca merda lo sapevo non tipo 30
secondi di video a 12 morti fantastico
porca [ __ ] morgan
niente niente se non volete il caso
l'ultima volta lo facciano così via
l'avete visto anche voi ok ma sei uno
stronzo a provare a giocare sto gioco
senza guardare prima o poi sarà
fantastico
[Musica]
ok ok il mio dio mio dio non saperlo
sabour lo sapevo questo lo sapevo lo sto
facendo anche se ci sono ok no già fatta
[Musica]
[Applauso]
adesso ci caliamo tutti tutti tranquilli
proprio tranquilli piano giugno suo
bravo ok effetti sono calmissimo sono
calmissimo che di quella [ __ ] io io sto
gioco lo devo a bollire dallo stesso
cliccato bloccato lo scherma [ __ ]
no no no no no praga è difficilissimo
cala [ __ ] no conta dove spuntato con
lo schifo gioco
dovete capire che ci sono giochi che io
non posso fare non posso non c'era prima
col cubo di merda è spuntato a caso non
c'era prima
ok ok ok su no no no no ho fatto prima
dovevano morire tutti atrocemente di una
morte atroce mentre di diarrea
no non dovevo saltare lì non dovevo fare
su cazzo che asciuga e l'ultimo lo
sapevo ci avrei scommesso
ho superato due ostacoli senza
conoscerli ho vinto tutto la strega o
superato gli ultimi due ostacoli senza
sapere ok giuro che non ho idea di come
sia possibile cioè a caso perché è come
non fosse dovrei stare anche un po
diritto cioè ho capito in ritardo però
ho capito
[ __ ] sì sì ok ho fatto no ma
perché il fano si giochi per ipad cosa
ardua dello scopo di star o no no no
c'era il checkpoint merda
sì l'ho preso ok già fatta all'amalgama
numero hanno rotto le palle perché
potevo incazzarmi ok lo sapevo che fanno
certo la guerra termonucleare no ok
facciamo così facciamo prima ok a caso
allora sto con te che cazzo è successo
che smaterializzato il ponte da solo
ragazzi non so se è normale
niente niente c'era anche era anche alla
fine fantastico devo saltare che caso
faccio e non ci arrivo non è possibile
adesso non è possibile
sì sì sì sì ok
l'ho fatto perché lo fa ci ho messo un
ora non pensavo si facesse così va in
the key to open the door devo trovare
una chiave c'è un cocktail posso bere
nel frattempo non posso bere [ __ ]
un'ospitalità esso posso fa schifo
regalato io userei quella gialla
non so perché mi piace non si apre un
cazzo perfetto da questa viola devo
provare tutto era un occhio che secondo
me non è così semplice come sembra
devo fare qualcos'altro che non vedo
anche se non ho capito cosa di preciso
ti può andare quassù ho capito fermina
ti stai mezzo e sel perché ho passato
due livelli così va a fan culo come non
è quella
mi sta venendo prima non ci crederò mai
non ci credo ma [ __ ] mezz'ora time
for coraggio ma [ __ ] tutto il
coraggio ragazzo ha messo anni e poi
dovrò tornare indietro né cosa devo fare
qua no mi chiamo scrivo per noi era
meglio era meglio quello di prima
veramente è stato assurdo ci sono messo
degli anni
niente non c'è mai stato un diamante poi
sono morto giusto che vai vai vai vai
vai veloce
si no no merda e assurdo sto livello si
va bene bravo bello lo zio bravo
no però è che fare qua lo prendere il
diamante da infor cuore
devo portare gli amanti al 9 scherziamo
ci sta tutta
la tua sorella go on e cosa così non ce
l'ha portati ma [ __ ] o ancora vaghi you
forget the gift to mimava lo sapevo che
devo portare il diamante st lurida
[ __ ] che non niente sono morto la
devo salvare si incazza pure perché non
l'ho portato il diamante in chiave anti
ski a queste donne sempre più esigenti
no no no beh piano benissimo dietro ma
non si può fare come ho fatto prima devo
ragionare lega terminati ma e non è il
mio forte e ragione sì sì no no mio di
ok ok ok bene così veloce no no no no no
no no no no no ok ok
si no minchia lucio fattaccio fatto a
calmi calmi emozionando basse
ok ok va bene celo celo non fare la
[ __ ] non fare la [ __ ] si che cazzo fa
cup bello mi cambia direzione ogni volta
che cambia la leva fantastico quindi si
va beh non ce la farò mai
cambia i tasti cazzo mi cambia i tasti è
impossibile devo prendere o come penso
farà un essere umano a giocare al suo
schifo non si può finire ogni volta che
cambia calmi un secondo che diventa
difficile adesso sì ho fatto due metri
ed è tanto per me
destra sinistra tua madre raga è assurdo
sì certo cielo quasi però c'è ma un
essere umano per fare sto livello deve
avere tre mani è impossibile
io cosa ho fatto non si sa come va bene
così devo prenderla no devo arrivarci
prima che questo devi devi veramente
avere tre braccia non puoi fare sti
ragazzi non si può fare il suo livello
adesso si gioca la merda devo dirti la
zia si gesù santo possiamo finire sto
livello grazie che già per arrivare
coach ha messo qualcosa come 15 anni no
è no proprio no c'è riguarda
l'importante è che non cambiano sti cosi
perché i tassi perché è assurdo come non
detto erano meglio i tasti o lo lancia
dalla finestra l'ipad giuro ma perché
non salto perché vi dove lo vuoi perché
sono stupido questa la risposta adesso
melo su chi ok perfetto ce n'è un altro
di sicuro non c'è ok ragazzi no no no mi
si sono invertiti i tasti di nuovo tua
sorella vende gelati adesso diventa
leggermente difficile perfetto cosa è
successo ci ripete conto che io ho fatto
ho vinto ho in mente quando ho fatto
cinque livelli 5 da quando siamo partiti
cinque news demo assenza o man in the
world è il più fantastico uomo sulla
terra ei beckham steve jobs george
clooney o slime non c'è scritto fa vj
quindi nessuna di queste l'al alhy
facciamo david beckham non è david
beckham george clooney che non sono
ovviamente made by the xenclient questo
il creatore sì lo sapevo già moresco
pica che concentri kiss of good day to
die basta la faccio più è stato
bellissimo proprio un gioco bello
ragazzi concludo qui perché è veramente
visto già pesa speranze è a dir poco
veramente non cercasse il video è
piaciuto come al solito lasciato un
commento mi piace anche a pacciani
facebook economy lo trattano descrizione
serio rischi discreta i cibi diamo in un
prossimo video belle ragazze